we have a square with a side length
equal to 7 that's tilted inside of a
rectangle with a height equal to six the
question is to solve for the width of
this rectangle when I first saw this
problem I built scaled models of the
square and the rectangle I first tilted
the square so that it would fit inside
of the rectangle and then I expanded the
width of the rectangle until it exactly
touched the square I then measured the
width would have to be approximately
8.17 but how can we solve it
mathematically the side of the square
has a length equal to 7. let X be the
width of the rectangle then we have
right angles here and here then this
blue angle is complementary to this
green angle and this blue angle is also
complementary to that same green angle
therefore this triangle is similar to
this triangle over here
this means that X over 7 is equal to 7
over 6 which means X is equal to 7
squared over six which equals 49 over 6
which is approximately 8.17 and that's
the answer